[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Well,
good morning, everyone.
I'm Jacquelline Fuller, and I'm
the president of Google.org,
which is Google's philanthropy.
And I am so pleased,
so, so pleased,
to be here today
with our friends.
This is Gavin McCormick,
from WattTime, Nada Malou,
from Médecins Sans Frontiers,
also known as Doctors Without
Borders, and Anandan,
from Wadhwani AI.
So I'm going to provide
a little bit of context
on Google.org itself and
the AI impact challenge,
and then we're going
to hear from some
of our winners about
the important work
that they are doing globally.
So Google.org is
Google's philanthropy,
and our mission is to help
bring together technologists,
such as all of you, and
experts on the front lines
who are dedicated to improving
the environment, education,
poverty.
To really solve
complex challenges,
and apply resources,
expertise, communications,
and reach, together,
to help us really
take a step change forward.
For anyone who was in
Moustapha's talk right
before this one, he talked about
how applying machine learning
can help us take a step change,
even when all we're doing
is changing the ML models,
and not even any changing
to the underlying data
and infrastructure.
So as Google.org, we
like to think about,
how can we help Google itself
with our own technologies
that we're applying
such as the flood
forecasting you might have
heard about in the keynote?
Well, we have a winner from
the AI Impact Challenge
who's applying those kinds
of techniques for landslides.
So the AI Impact Challenge
itself was global in nature.
We provided $25 million in a
pool and opened it to the world
and said, how would you use
artificial intelligence,
machine learning, to make a
huge difference in improving
the world in your specific area?
And then the winners receive
the funding, the resources,
but also expertise.
They all get assigned help
from Googlers from our research
group.
They have access to an
accelerator called Credits.
So basically it's a partnership,
an extended partnership,
to see how Google can help
them carry out their vision.
And what was so exciting is when
we first did this competition,
it came out of a
conversation, actually,
with Sundar Pichai,
our CEO, who said
he is so excited to see
how AI can be applied
not only at companies
like Google,
but for the front line heroes
who are really trying to change
the world when it
comes to global health
and environmental concerns.
How can we apply AI in
those settings as well?
So out of that conversation we
launched the impact challenge,
not really sure exactly
how it would turn out.
We partnered with Jeff Dean,
the Google Research team,
and the efforts being led by
Bridget and Molly, who are here
and can talk to you afterwards
if you're interested.
And so we put it out
there in the world.
And we had more than 2,600
high-quality applications
from more than 119 countries.
And from those, we distilled
it down to 20 winners.
And we have three
of them here today.
So the conversation
is really going
to be to understand
what you all are doing,
to hear about your
inspiring stories.
And I think we probably
have some technologists
in the room who are really
interested in thinking
about, how can they
apply technology
to their issue's areas?
The causes that they
care about most.
So maybe you'll have some
advice and inspiring words
for the audience as well.
But why don't we start
by each of you just
sharing your name, a
little bit of your bio,
and then tell us a little
bit about the problem
that your organization
is trying to solve.
And Gavin, should
we start with you?
GAVIN MCCORMICK: Sure.
So I'm Gavin
McCormick, co-founder
and executive
director at WattTime.
I am not a developer
by training.
I'm an economist, so
what am I doing here?
I had worked formerly at
the US Department of Energy,
and then was a PhD student
at UC Berkeley, when
a new form of statistics
was coming out
in economics, the so-called
credibility revolution.
And it's being applied
to environmental problems
to solve problems
that were previously
considered impossible.
So one of those is, where
is this energy coming from?
We used to think
you couldn't know.
Turns out with new algorithms,
we can flip a light switch
and say what power
plant precisely
will provide a little bit
more electricity if you
plug in a phone, or use
an electric vehicle,
or use some energy.
And the only reason
that's interesting,
is it turns out it
changes incredibly fast.
So if you wait
five minutes, that
could be the difference
between getting energy
from a coal plant or getting
energy from a solar panel.
And so there's actually
this entirely new dimension
in environmentalism that
data just opened up.
Instead of just
using less energy
and helping the
environment, let's use it
at very specific times.
So my organization
WattTime was founded
at a hackathon
where we figured out
there's about $20 billion
IoT devices worldwide
that can actually
have some code that
is very flexible and exact
to when they use energy.
So we produce an API
that says, what time
is the best moment to use
energy if you want to have
less environmental impact?
Doesn't make any money, but
it's a really significant source
of emissions reduction
for climate change and air
pollution worldwide.
And one of the interesting
things about it
is, it was only possible because
the US federal government has
this amazing open training
data set on all the pollution
from all the power
plants in America.
Basically no other
country has that.
And so WattTime
realized that if we
wanted to provide emissions
reductions in other countries,
if we wanted to make
this a global technology,
we needed some way to know
what's going on at every power
plant in the world.
So for this project,
what we are going to do
is use visual recognition
software and machine learning
on imagery taken by
satellites of all the power
plants in the world.
And it turns out, if you
use the right types of data,
such as infrared
imagery, you can actually
detect how much
pollution is coming out
of every single power
plant worldwide,
based on a satellite
infrastructure.
So first of all,
that was kind of fun.
But then the other
piece of the puzzle
is we quickly discovered that a
lot of other environmental NGOs
want the same data.
So I'm here
representing WattTime,
but we're actually
partnering with a lot
of the biggest environmental
NGOs in the world.
We decided to collectively
pool our resources
and go on in this
project together.
So I think it's fun
that Carbon Tracker will
be using this to figure out,
what are all the cases where
actually it would be cheaper
to use renewable energy
than fossil fuels?
Can we just shut down a
lot of world's coal plants?
World Resources Institute
will be using this to see,
are any countries polluting
more than they legally
are bound to under
the Paris treaty?
There's a whole bunch of
different environmental
applications for
the same project.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Great, thanks Gavin.
Nada?
NADA MALOU: Thank you.
So I'm Doctor Nada Malou.
I'm a PhD in microbiology.
And so after my PhD, I decided
to work with the Doctors
Without Borders, or Médecins
Sans Frontieres in French.
So we are an international,
medical, humanitarian
organization providing care
for populations in need,
because of war context, because
of outbreaks like Ebola,
cholera, or for populations who
are excluded from their health
care system.
So we work in more
than 70 countries.
And my work for Médecins
Sans Frontieres,
or Doctors Without Borders,
as a microbiologist,
is to identify diagnostic
tools that can help to diagnose
infection in the patients that
we receive in our different
projects.
So I worked in Ghana
and Mali in Africa,
where I was mainly
specialized and worked
in pediatric
population, so children
arriving with malnutrition
and having also an infection
with the bacteria.
And then I worked in the Middle
East with war wounded patients.
So those patients were also
arriving in our facility
with infection.
And it was very important
to diagnose this infection
in order to avoid amputation
or a medical complication.
So the challenge in
identifying diagnostic tools
for low and middle
income countries
is that most of the
diagnostic tools
that we have are not adapted to
the constraints of the field.
Here in the US, or even in
Europe, if you are sick,
you have fever, you
can go to the hospital.
They take your blood.
They do a test, and
they will tell you
which bacteria is
causing the infection
and what is the
most effective drug
to use to treat this infection.
Those tests are not available
in the context where we work.
So the question was, why
they are not available?
So there are many reasons
to the problem of access,
but also the fact that
they are not adapted.
So one of the reasons
is the limitation
in term of human resources
and trained human resources.
So the idea for us was to try
to find a solution in order
to make the interpretation and
the use of this test easier
and available for the
majority of those patients
that we are seeing.
And I think you all
heard about this problem
of antimicrobial resistance.
We know that for
the coming decades,
it is going to be one of the
major public health threats.
We estimate that in 2050, the
death of 10 million patients
will be attributable to
antimicrobial resistance.
And it's going to be mainly
in the Asian and African
continent.
So it's very urgent
for us to give access
to those diagnostic tools in
order to target the bacteria
and to target the effective
treatment for the patients
in a timely manner.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Thanks, great.
Anandan?
ANANDAN: Thank you.
My name is Anandan.
Let me start with a little
bit of a personal story,
because it's very relevant.
I tell my friends and colleagues
I've been doing AI as long
as most of them have been
alive, and in many cases more.
I started my PhD in 1981,
went to UMass Amherst
in computer vision.
Had a good, driving research
and publishing career.
I was the head of
computer vision
in Microsoft Research in
Redmond for a number of years.
But in 2004, I felt like I
wanted to do something more
and saw the opportunity
to build technology
for the development
of social good
as a potential agenda
from a research side.
And so, convinced Microsoft to
set up a research lab in India.
And I went and set up
that lab and ran it.
Although it does much more than
technology for social good,
it did become known
for that work.
In fact we spun out
a couple of NGOs.
Nine years of that, came back.
Then in 2017, I met two
philanthropic donors.
Doctors Romesh Wadhwani,
who lives in California,
and his brother, Sunil
Wadhwani, both of Indian origin,
but done well in
the tech industry.
Well-known philanthropists.
And we're looking to see how
they can apply their ideas
and money towards social good.
So they got the idea
of actually setting up
a research institute
that would build
AI solutions for a variety
of social domain problems,
and then get it implemented.
And they tapped me to be CEO.
So here I thought,
here's my second chance
to change the world.
So I quit my job, what I
was doing at that time,
and went back to
India to set it up.
We started, and it took
us a while to launch.
We started last year in
February the Wadhwani Institute
for Artificial Intelligence
in Bombay, Mumbai.
And because of the importance
of the agenda and how hot AI is,
the prime minister of India came
and inaugurated our institute.
Our charter is really simple.
We want to identify societal
domain problems specifically
to help the under-served
communities.
There are roughly 3
or 4 billion people
in the world who don't
benefit from the kind of AI
that we all do on
an everyday basis.
They don't take Uber.
They don't do search.
All that kind of stuff.
And it doesn't
affect their lives.
And many of them, in
fact, most of them,
are typically wards
of the government.
In fact, their lives depend
a lot on government programs.
These are poor farmers
trying to do agriculture
at a very basic level.
Small hold farmers, like one
acre of land, or something.
Basic health care.
There are 900 million
people in India
who depend on the public
health care system, which
has about 30,000 doctors.
And this is true of a lot
of the developing world.
Basic level of education.
Literacy is still a problem.
But beyond that,
financial inclusion.
Getting credit if you are a poor
person is next to impossible.
And basic infrastructures, clean
water, utilities, and stuff
like that, and done in
an efficient manner.
So we saw the opportunity
that AI, in fact,
is this technology that can
learn the particular conditions
locally and be able to develop
solutions to address them.
Because these problems vary
a lot from place to place,
and you can't do a one shoe
fits all type of approach.
So we took that up.
We are a bit more than a year
old now, having a great time.
A couple of projects in
health and one agriculture.
The agriculture one is the one
that's funded by the Google AI
Impact Challenge.
Really exciting.
I have a team of about 25,
30 people now, growing.
My vice president for
product and programs,
Raghu, is in the front row.
You can talk to
him later as well.
Thank you.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: So when we
started this program, the AI
Impact Challenge,
it was because we
thought AI can help bring new
technology to old challenges.
And that it's really
important to bring
the experts who
know the issue best,
the people who are closest
to the problem, together
with not only the tools,
but also expertise
from Google and others.
So what was the
moment, or was there
a specific moment, where
the light kind of went on
and you thought, you know what?
AI might be able to solve this
in a way that it hasn't before.
NADA MALOU: I
remember that moment.
And as a medical person, I
was not having a solution.
I was having an idea, but
no solution to this need.
So I spent a few
years to implement
in those microbiology
laboratories and training
a lot of lab technicians.
And what I noticed is that
training them to do the test
was very easy, and
they were very good.
But then how to interpret
the test and how to use it
was much more difficult
and takes a lot of time.
That's why in
Europe, or in the US,
we have clinical microbiologists
who study for years
to have this expertise.
And the moment where I thought,
OK, this is not sustainable,
we need to find a
solution, was in Yemen
where we opened a
microbiology lab because there
was a medical need.
The patients were
arriving infected,
and it was important
for us to treat them.
So we opened that
lab, and I was not
able to find expertise locally.
And I was neither able to
send expert microbiologists
because it was a difficult
security context.
And so they were sending
me the results by email.
And I was checking each results
and validating each result,
and I thought this
is not possible.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
That doesn't scale.
NADA MALOU: No, this
is not sustainable.
And it was a crazy idea.
And by coincidence,
one day, I spoke
with one of my PhD friends.
And so he tried to
convince me to use
very complicated technology.
And I said, no, the
solution is easy.
I want something very simple.
I want to take my phone to
take a picture of the test
and to have the results
and the interpretation.
And he called me
three months later,
and he's a bioinformatician.
So he called me
three months later
and he said, we can do it.
We can do it.
And for me, it was like,
OK, maybe, if you want.
And one year and a half after,
here we are with a prototype,
and with something that can
be really a game changer.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Anandan,
did you have a moment like that?
ANANDAN: Last summer,
after we started,
we started looking out for what
problems we want to work on.
Because of the
initial visibility,
we got a lot of people who were
interested in talking to us.
However, when we
started learning
about how to go about it, what
we realized was fundamentally,
there are three questions
that we have to answer.
What should we work on?
How do we go about
building it in order
so that it will be effective?
And how do we get it deployed
and eventually scale?
And to this, what
we realized was--
see, in commercial
domain, there is a market.
Companies like Google
or other companies
know how to develop the market.
In social domain, well,
there is a problem of course.
The capacity to pay is
not there among the people
that you are trying to help.
But even if we find
a model to do that,
the market is
extremely fragmented.
The approach to getting to
your audience in one state, one
city, one village, one region,
of one part of the world,
is very different from another.
Because every place
you go, there's
some kind of a program that
is a government program,
or other NGO
program, that exists.
And you have to
work through them.
In fact, they exist
simply because no one else
is taking care of them.
So what we learned
is that in order
to answer those
questions, we have
to partner with organizations
that are capable of execution
and delivery.
So we consulted with them a lot.
So they became the source
of problems for us,
identifying what to work on.
But equally then, they are also
the people who can co-create.
Because if they are willing
to put in their energy
and interest in working with
us, the solution we produce
will be the right
one for them to use.
And one of the other
things we learned
in this process is the primary
users of our technology
are not the end users.
Not the farmer,
not the poor mother
in a village who is pregnant.
But in fact, front-line
workers, health workers,
front-line agriculture
and extension workers,
who are the advice givers.
Because they are capable
of using that technology,
and they are part
of a system of care.
So we needed to learn
from the partners
to build solutions for that
kind of a use scenario.
And finally, we have to work
with government in order
to scale.
Because all these solutions,
only the governments
have the capacity to scale at
the national or international
level.
And you know how
challenging that can
be, as governments come
and go, bureaucrats
change, and everything.
But what we learned is
that there is actually
experienced groups of NGOs
and other partners and donor
organizations, like
the Gates Foundation
and so on, who know
how to do this.
So they became our teachers
on how we go about doing this.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: So it's
early days with AI, especially
applied AI, on some of
these kinds of challenges.
So as you think about
your road ahead,
what are some of the
biggest risks or challenges
that you see popping
up in front of you?
Sure.
GAVIN MCCORMICK: I think
for us, privacy and security
is a surprisingly big deal.
So this is supposed to be
a massively collaborative
open-data project.
But we're talking about a
literal global panopticon
that can see critical
energy infrastructure
in every country.
And that would be really,
really easy to abuse.
So for us the challenge
of, how do you
make data as open as
possible to collaborators,
while simultaneously
making sure that it can't
be used for security risks?
Or there are fossil fuel
companies that would love,
instead of decreasing emissions,
to increase oil consumption.
How do we make a system
that's as open as possible
without enabling abuse?
And so we're currently working
on unusual contract structures
and unusual data
structures that we would
consider semi open-source.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Risks, challenges you see?
ANANDAN: So I mean,
there are actually
three levels of challenges.
The simplest one
is the AI itself.
I think that's actually the
one that we know how to do
and can be done.
The medium one is data.
In the social domain,
data is not around,
and data collection
is not very easy.
In fact, whatever data
that exists is bad,
meaning that it's
not good quality.
It's often false, meaning
people make up stories.
And it's sparse.
All the information is
not available everywhere.
And historic data is
not usually available.
It's in silos and not
one centralized place.
So every aspect of
data challenge exists.
But, that said, it
can actually be met.
You can actually work, create
a system of data creation,
and work through that.
The biggest challenge is
actually the execution.
Because the kind
of organizations
that you have to work with are
actually limited in funding
and limited in capacity, and
they're working short-handed,
really.
And a diverse range of them.
And potentially for
us, the risk factor
always is the program risk.
So unless we believe that
there exists current programs,
like for instance, in
our carbon farming work.
There is an agriculture
extension system
for pest counting and
pest management, which
we can improve or
replace through AI
that will actually
solve the problem.
Then we'll feed into the system.
And the only way to do
that is to look for places
where there is a system
approach that you
can leverage and so on.
So that's the biggest challenge.
NADA MALOU: I
think we're sharing
all the same challenges, at
least for the two first ones.
So for us, yes, the AI part
is one of the challenges.
The quality and the data is
also one of the challenges
because we want to identify
resistance in bacteria.
So we need to cover the maximum
patterns of resistance, which
means that we need
to have access
to a huge library of
resistance pictures.
And we need to be
always updated.
Because if bacteria
decide to mutate tomorrow
and to appear
resistant in a new way,
we need to have the
possibility to cover this.
And finally, for diagnostic
and medical care in general,
I think there is this
debate about, be careful,
AI is going to replace doctors,
nurses, and lab technicians.
I think it's very important
to say that it facilitates,
but it will never replace a
clinician, or lab technician,
or a microbiologist.
This is just going to help
us to gain also some time
in order to train and
to build the capacity
of our human resources
in the field.
Because the problem is today.
And we need to find
a solution for today.
So in terms of, I
think, communication
and the way that we
present the tool,
we should be very careful
that the medical professionals
understand that they are
not going to be replaced.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Let's talk a moment
about the power of partnership.
So I think we're all familiar
with the African proverb,
if you want to go fast, go
alone, if you want to go far,
go together.
But going together
can be complicated.
But we know that
none of these kind
of global, audacious,
bold, innovative solutions
are going to be able to
be accomplished by one
small organization alone.
So maybe some of your
experiences or thoughts
that you've had as you
sought out the right partners
and built that collaboration?
ANANDAN: OK.
So I'll give you a couple
of different examples.
In the front-line
health case, we
talked to a bunch of front-line
health organizations,
and felt like triaging by
front-line workers at home care
might be a good problem.
And then we talked to
the Gates Foundation.
They organized a
couple of workshops,
inviting about 30 or 40 of
their grantees to day workshops.
We learned a lot, and
two things happened.
One is that these
organizations helped
us realize that certain problems
in maternal and child care,
like infant mortality, actually
were more urgent and doable.
So we changed our mind.
But moreover in that process,
they signed up to work with us.
They said, you know,
if you do this,
we'll actually be interested.
On the other problem
that we're working on,
tuberculosis
eradication, in India
there is a tuberculosis
care system
managed by something called
the Central TB Division.
Anything you do, it's
better you work with them,
because the only real TB
data available is theirs.
I mean, they own it.
So we have become an AI partner
for the Central TB Division,
but that also means being
part of their discussions
and planning and so on.
But it's very valuable
because it tells us where
we can actually make progress.
In cotton farming, the project
for which we are funded,
there is actually an
agriculture extension program
that the state government has.
So we start with them, and they
introduced us to that system.
But then we also found that
there is a private sector,
not-for-profit, kind
of an organization,
called Better Cotton
Initiative, that can actually
be an early adopter
of the solution
and allow us to file
it and try ourself.
So we simultaneously partnered
with these organizations.
And in each case,
once they agree,
they take you to the problem
domain, take you to the people.
Data collection becomes
easier because they
will do it for you.
They'll give you the
opening to do it.
And then execution, of course.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Gavin?
GAVIN MCCORMICK: Thank you.
So partnerships can be hard for
a slightly awkward introvert,
I have learned.
But I think that it's
really interesting
that in the business
sector, I think,
partnerships are important.
And I think for impact they're
just absolutely not negotiable.
You absolutely have to do it.
It has been stunning
to see the impact that
has happened in the climate
movement in the last year,
as a lot of NGOs have started
to say, why would we stand up
separate technology stacks?
Why don't we just
all collaborate?
And it's been amazing.
95% of companies worldwide
have a sustainability team
that uses the World
Resources Institute protocol.
We just called them up
and said, why don't you
have all our data for free?
We won't charge you,
and you'll distribute it
to every company in
the world for free.
You won't charge us.
And then a similar deal with
RMI, 90% of renewable energy
developers worldwide.
So the scale and
speed of progress
has just been stunning for
what a little team of 10 people
can accomplish because
everyone's willing to work
together in our field suddenly.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
But to do that, you
have to overcome what's known
as database hugging syndrome,
right?
So every NGO, every
company, every entity
wants to hold on to their data.
But sounds like, in this case,
you are willing to share.
GAVIN MCCORMICK:
And we've done it
through a really interesting
legal mechanism, which
I think has potential
for impact, which
is that it's shared under
what we call a mission source
license.
So we can get access
to their IP and vice
versa as long as we have the
same environmental mission.
And I think that that is a
really interesting innovation
that will apply to
other projects as well.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Well,
this room contains a group.
This is a very self-selected
group of folks.
I think technologists,
developers,
people who are really interested
in thinking about applying
AI to improving environment,
social issues, poverty,
women's rights.
So to this room,
that's filled with,
I think, aspiring and inspired
pragmatic solutions folks, what
would be your words
of advice or maybe
some lessons learned
that you have
for people who are
thinking about how
they can help contribute?
How they can be part
of applying technology
to these huge global challenges?
GAVIN MCCORMICK: I would
certainly say, collaborate,
collaborate, collaborate.
For two reasons.
One, you might be surprised
at the low state of tech
in the NGO sector.
If you're not already familiar,
it's often just stunning
what a really good
developer can do
in four hours of volunteering.
We've been really struck.
And the other is, it's really
easy for well-meaning code
to actually cause
harm in sectors
where the issues can
be really complicated.
It's so valuable
to talk to subject
matter experts first about
what would really help.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: That
was very clear and concise.
NADA MALOU: Yeah,
collaboration is a key.
And for us, for
example, if I did not
have my friend, who has this
bioinformatic background
to translate from a medical
need to a technical solution,
we would not be here.
So I think it's very important
to find a bridge between us.
Because as a medical person,
I know what would be the need,
but you are the one who
can make it possible
and who can bring the solution.
And we are doing this
every day now, a project.
The developer who is working
on this application, Marco
Bastucci, who is in the
room, he speaks a language
that I don't speak.
And to be honest, most of
the time I don't understand.
And it's the same for him.
He does not understand when
I speak about bacteria,
infection, resistance.
So we need to find
away from both sides
to translate and to make the
understanding of both sides
easier.
So people like bioinformatic
people can be a way,
but simplifying the
medical development
language can be a key element
to ensure this collaboration.
ANANDAN: So I used
to be a professor,
so I can pontificate.
I think I'll break
it into three parts.
Why you should get into
AI for social good,
how you should do it, and
what you should not do.
See, I have an academic
background, published enough,
and I worked in the industry.
I know what tech
transfer takes and how
it is to work in a
very disciplined,
structured environment.
However, if you want to
completely create and work
on something that is
kind of completely new,
you need that space.
So you go to the place
where there is the least
amount of people working on it.
And actually, building
technology solutions
for the social domain,
it's completely empty.
There is not enough people
like you out there doing it.
And in fact, one of the
things that we want to do
is to attract more people
to come and collaborate.
You don't have to
leave your job,
but you can find a
way to contribute.
But the opportunity to shape
the direction is very big,
and you don't have
to follow what
is the next greatest
breakthrough in deep learning
and do that.
You can just solve
some other problem
that you define yourself.
So to me, it's the most
rewarding thing you can do.
And, you know, if
you do it right,
you can begin to see it having
tangible impact on people
that you care about,
lives around you.
How to do it?
You have to do it fundamentally,
with a collaborative mind
like Nada was saying,
which is like, you
can't think of the
end-to-end problem,
you don't know
how to execute it.
So you need to be very open,
and to listen to and take
some risks on
collaborating with people.
And change your course if
you need to, dynamically.
It has to be very
agile, but it also
has to be something where
you know what you can do
but work with other people.
And what you should not do--
and this is kind of important.
It's not about advancing the
state of AI or science, which
is a fantastic thing to do.
If your solution cannot
be implemented and scaled,
it's not worth anything.
It can be the greatest
piece of technology.
So you have to look at
programs and systems that
can help you scale.
I mean, some day we hope we
will change the system itself.
But you are going
to do that only when
you learn how the system works.
And you can't sort of
start doing something,
and throw it out and see
that it will actually work.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: So
I'm going to open it up
to questions in the
audience in just a minute.
So you can go to the
mics here if you have
questions for the panelists.
But this has been
incredibly inspiring.
I think reading over
these applications
is one of the hardest
things I've actually ever
had to do in my
12 years at Google
because there were so many
amazing ideas and teams.
But you all really stood out.
Just wondering if you have
any final words that you
would like to say to this
audience, these technologists.
GAVIN MCCORMICK: I think
it's much easier to jump
in to impact than I realized.
My organization was only
created because I showed up
at a hackathon and
some developers
told me what was possible.
And we built something
on that day of.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
See, good things
can come out of hackathons.
GAVIN MCCORMICK: One day.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
We have our doubts.
NADA MALOU: So for
me, it's in the title.
It's the impact.
I think it's very important
to visualize the impact
and how it's going to be used.
And at least for
medical questions,
I think it's a new
era with the AI.
But the solution,
we should in advance
think about once it is ready,
how this is going to be used
and what is going
to be the impact.
And for me, it's an advice, but
also the biggest challenge when
you think about the project.
ANANDAN: I once
had the privilege
of having Jim Kajiya, who's
a very well-known graphics
researcher, a pioneer,
as my direct manager.
And we would have these
one-on-one's periodically.
And at the end of it, he would
say, OK, go change the world.
That's basically the best thing.
It doesn't matter how you
do it, where you do it.
Once you get that as your
goal, you'll have fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]